one of the most annoying Trends these
days is the trend of making things into
Trends we've discussed this in the past
jenz is in particular is obsessed with
taking the most benow and commonplace
activities repackaging them with a new
name and hashtag and acting like they
invented the idea and it seems like
they're finally getting to the end of
the list of routine human behaviors to
trendify because the latest Trend which
is not a trend is the activity that up
until now has been known as going for a
walk CBS News has the breaking news
report a new trend on Tik Tok may
actually have some health benefits
something called Silent walking is
trending on the social media app where
Tik Tok users are encouraging people to
walk without airpods or headphones
podcasts or music and without walking
companions simply walk in silence
without stimulation distraction free
proponents say it allows people to be
alone with our thoughts to feel more
relaxed to enjoy nature to be more
Mindful and to think more clearly
therapists agree we're bombarded with so
much noise all day long that silent
walking can allow us to escape even if
for just a short period of time so
you're not only getting the physical
benefits but the mental health benefits
as well
now needless to say this is incredible
incredible news some local news stations
around the country have been covering
the trend as well because it's such big
news to be clear uh again they have done
actual news reports about
walking here's one and a new trend on
Tik Tok may actually have some health
benefits what's this all about okay so
it's something called Silent walking
okay have you heard of it no it's
trending on on the social media app
where Tik tokers are actually
encouraging people to go out and walk
without airpods or headphones without
podcast and music playing and without
walking companions simply walk in
silence without stimulation distraction
free proponents say it allows people to
be alone with their thoughts they feel
more relaxed they can enjoy nature they
can feel more Mindful and think more
clearly and therapists are in agreement
we're bombarded with so much noise all
day long that silent walking can allow
us to escape even if for just a short
period of time so you're not only
getting the physical benefits of the
actual walking but you're getting some
mental health benefits as well now this
amazing idea the idea called Walking is
so radical and revolutionary that U
you're probably wondering who invented
it well I can't tell you who invented
walking um I don't think any one
particular person did but I can tell you
who has given herself credit for
inventing it that is a Tik Tok
influencer named Maddie who made this
video about the silent walking movement
that she believes she pioneered
watch I'm committing it to one silent
walk a day not me unintentionally
starting a movement it's called Silent
walking and it's about to change your
life so this all started when my
nutritionist recommended that I start
walking 30 minutes a day instead of
doing like insane cardio like I used to
those workouts were making my body
inflamed that's a story for another time
and as I was about to go out on my first
30 minute walk my sweet boyfriend
challenged me to walk without
distractions no airpods no podcast no
music Just Me Myself and I and at first
I was like no my anxiety could never
which is probably what you're thinking
but something within me was like let me
just try it and look the first two
minutes are Mayhem your mind is racing
you're going to have anxiety something
happens after 2 minutes where your brain
just gets into this Flow State and
everything is quiet and suddenly you can
hear yourself look the universe and your
intuition comes to you through Whispers
so if you're never alone with your
thoughts and you never get quiet you're
going to miss the Whispers and those
whispers are the most important to be
paying attention to after 30 minutes of
Silent walking I suddenly had the
clarity that I had been always looking
for the brain fog lifted suddenly all
these ideas are flowing into me because
I'm giving them space to enter when
you're listening to a podcast or music
you're distracting yourself you're not
letting the signs and the ideas have
space to come to you every time I finish
a silent walk I have a new idea for my
business I've untangled a weird
situation in my head that I've been
ruminating over and I feel like a lot of
my current question marks get
answered okay now I think I know you're
thinking a few things you're thinking
first of all that she apparently has a
whole other fascinating story about how
cardio makes her body inflamed
unfortunately she is saving that epic
Saga for another time so we'll have to
stay tuned you're also thinking that she
seems to struggle with the concept of
Silent this is supposed to be a silent
walk and yet she didn't shut up the
entire time so give it to a woman to
talk for 25 minutes about the concept of
being silent of course the activity that
she's suggesting even if she doesn't
seem to have mastered it herself is
indeed very healthy and worthwhile
walking in general is an advisable
activity something that every
able-bodied person should try to fit
into their day every day really and
walking in silence allowing yourself to
think to contemplate to experience your
immediate surroundings is the best form
of walking uh you you cannot have a
healthy inner life or any inner life at
all really if you don't have silence
to avoid silence is to avoid yourself
your own mind your Consciousness so I
have no problem with silent walking you
know it I think it's a very a very good
practice the problem is that is that is
the ignorance that leads these Tik Tock
influencers to believe that they came up
with the idea themselves she started a
movement she brags I mean you might as
well claim that you're the first person
to mow your lawn or take a shower or
microwave a bag of popcorn hey I started
a movement everybody first first I tied
my shoes and now everyone else is tying
theirs too this will change your life
Autumn is in full swing which in my home
means cozy nights in with my family
these crisp autumn nights are made so
much better thanks to my friends at
Tommy John The Perfect Blend of comfort
and breathability Tommy John loungewear
has a level of softness I've never
experienced before it's like it was
designed to uh envelop you in a world of
pure luxury as I always say when you
wear Tommy John you're so much more
comfortable uh that you can do
everything better even their underwear
has dozens of comfort Innovations Tommy
John uses a breathable lightweight
moisture wicking fabric with four times
the stretch of competing Brands it can
keep you 7 degrees cooler than cotton
with over 20 million pairs sold and
thousands of festar reviews men Across
America are loving their Tommy John's
every purchase is backed by Tommy John's
best pair you'll ever wear it's free
guarantee you can get 20% off your first
order right now at Tommy john.com Walsh
that's 20% off at Tommy john.com Walsh C
site for details
now perhaps this is less ignorance than
it is arrogance maybe it's healthy mix
of both and this is the consequence of
having younger Generations that live in
their own bubble severed from or
willfully ignoring the wisdom and
guidance of their ancestors because what
Maddie says about the value of cutting
out all the noise is mostly true of
course but if she'd been paying
attention to anything but Tik Tok and
Instagram she would know that a great
many wise and intelligent people through
history have already said quite a lot
about you know contemplative silence and
its spiritual and psychological benefits
but like so many in her generation she
hasn't paid attention to what anyone has
said about anything so she believes
she's stumbled upon some hidden truth
that 10 billion people before her
managed to figure out without any of the
Fanfare or hashtags now I say that she's
a mostly right because she can't help
but Veer off into the self-help change
your life in three easy steps nonsense
at the end she says that every time she
walks down the street in silence she
comes up with some great idea for her
business or she solves some riddle that
she's been by and she's left with a
feeling of clarity but the truth is that
walking in silence is not a magic trick
it's not going to deliver the secrets of
the universe to you most of the time uh
you won't think of anything profound or
life-changing and if you decide to um
contemplate in Silence with the
expectation that brilliant insights and
profitable business ideas will pop into
your head automatically as a reward then
you're certain to get nothing out of it
that's because the main benefit of
having moments of silence is simply that
it gives you an opportunity to be human
to exist in the current moment to think
about anything at all to be something
other than an overstimulated automaton
constantly consuming content just for
the sake of it okay that's why you
should have silence in your life for its
own sake just because just because
you're a person and people are supposed
to have that and that's why the video I
just played of this woman is uh actually
quite disturbing because Maddie says
that she was initially terrified of
walking down the street in Silence the
first two minutes were Mayhem she claims
now think about that for a moment two
minutes two minutes without listening to
something or looking at her phone caused
internal chaos a mental crisis two
minutes it was a great challenge to
Simply exist for two minutes without any
form of electronic engagement this was a
harrowing ordeal for her and and not
only that but she's walking the whole
time I mean imagine imagine if she tried
actually here's here's a you know this
is like the you know the next the next
level okay from from Silent walking try
this try this try silent sitting try
sitting somewhere without any engagement
without looking at your phone for five
minutes and just sitting there and and
I'm not saying you're meditating or
doing yoga you're just sitting somewhere
and you're existing and you're thinking
imagine doing thats because at least
when you're walking you have the
stimulation of walking you're seeing
things did you know that like that's
something people used to do all the time
it you you would just you would have
times in during your day just kind of
like sitting there and you're just
sitting that's all you're doing and
you're thinking and that's it that's a
thing people used to do a
lot well she they're not even she's
madd's not even close to that that's
like that's 10 years down the line she
that's that is uh that's she's not even
JV that's Varsity that's D1 college
level um anyway she's sure that that
most in her audience uh will have the
same experiences her uh that it will be
just as challenging for them and she's
probably right because this generation
is so overstimulated so attached to
their phones so digitally dependent that
walking down the street for two minutes
in silence two minutes it's like
climbing some great Summit this is their
Mount
Everest that's why they consider walking
in silence to be revolutionary it is so
far outside of their normal experience
and requires so much effort on their
part that they assume they've discovered
something
new they don't realize what that that it
is in fact the most accessible and
normal human experience made
inaccessible and abnormal for them
because they have been raised like
robots rather than people which isn't
their fault to be fair we have now a
generation of human beings multiple
Generations en counting who don't know
how to Simply exist they don't know how
to be in the world how to be human they
don't know how to do it they only know
how to be consumers consumers of
products of content of light of noise of
sounds of images and they have to have
that bombarding them all the time or
they just they can't they don't know
what to
do many of them have spent have have
never in their lives spent even two
minutes at a time not consuming think
about that they're probably millions of
people walking around who have never
spent two minutes not consuming
something it is terrifying to think that
we will soon live in a world exclusively
populated by people like this people who
don't know how to be
people that's what we really learn from
the silent walking
Trend and that is why we are not
canceling gen Z for this rather I think
it is the parents who raised them this
way who are
today uh canceled if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wallow Twitter
page hope to see you there God speed